ora us pessoal domingo mais um vídeo e
os bons sinais como fazer uma pistola
que disparam balas de papel neste caso
eles por disparar bolinhas delsoft só
que eu encomendo ainda não chegaram e
terão que levar namorar um caninho sei o
que se passa lá só pra vocês não ficarem
sem vídeo então decidi fazer usando
bolinhas de papel é só ir lá tupelo em
troca no final poder com fita para não
ser usar tudo aí com vocês podem ver se
paro muito banho é certa e tem alguma
força
por isso você deve usar óculos de
proteção e não podem disparar contra
ninguém é como se fosse um brinquedo uma
brincadeira com armas nero armas da
esoft vocês têm que usar a proteção que
o solo e essas normas todas de segurança
se vocês forem crianças peçam ajuda o
duto ok porque vai ver que uma parte
mais difícil do tutorial é primeira
coisa você tem que fazer uma rifa e
depois tem que ir lá uma folha volta das
tarifas de modo a fazer um tubinho caso
vocês não tenham percebido bem como
fazer rifa eu vou deixar um link de
inscrição vocês carregam lá e vão ser
direcionados com um tutorial ensinar só
como fazer rifas detalhadamente modo que
fique bem forte aqui mesmo que os três
de várias medidas
o cano aquela parte grande tem 15
centímetros depois há uma parte incerta
e item 5 partes que tem 5 cm orientam
pelas medidas contando os quadrinhos
desta coisa aqui que o tenente plástico
fundo e agora vocês vão ter que recuar
vejam que cada segmento vai ligeiramente
para trás como se fosse mesmo que ela
parta garras da arma cair e quando
querem posto com cola porém em cima da
mesa vai tentar um crime para que fique
tudo certinho direitinho aqui estou aqui
mostrar a inclinação e agora lançado uma
rifa podem usar aquela inicialmente está
pra fazer aquela proteção do dedo da
arma alguém diz que os comentários
começaram esta parte que me esqueci ó
agora lembrei
aí é só coar é muito importante vocês
por estas partes do força porque se
vocês deixarem arma conta inicialmente
ela ficou muito frágil
então tem que fazer mesmo esta coisa que
corrija juros força que estou a fazer
leilão esta parte
eu já tenho um carinho e é só contornar
a volta da partida gravar matéria do
punho acho que o público pensa em como
como guardar armas mas isso não é só
fazer a forma à volta
se vocês não quiserem está volta
estragos em dois tempos mas se vocês
fizerem a sua parte ea volta fiquei
mesmo muito muito resistente
vocês podem comprovar este pois ainda
estou a pensar por alguma coisa volta
desta partida para o papel e fazer um
[ __ ] mesmo mais realista
se eu fizer isso depois de uma
fotografia na fanpage está no link da
inscrição e já estão as coisas ganham
100 mil inscritos salva estou muito
feliz e por isso vou fazer um concurso
brevemente esta semana vai aparecer no
vídeo explicar detalhadamente o que
vocês têm que fazer para ganhar os
prêmios e essas coisas todas
aí o canal crise pt já chegou em mim eu
também só que ainda não sei se vou fazer
alguma coisa lá para o inglês ainda não
é o meu forte apesar de estar aqui em
inglaterra e vejam que estou fazendo
agora o gatilho que é bastante simples
que é mais ou menos 1 uma para o maior
que a outra e depois vocês são encaixe
clube pois tem que ter cuidado quando
você apanha proteção à volta deixar dois
tubinhos ensino amigo charlie e mais um
por baixo e quer fazer proteção e vai
ser bastante simples só quando vocês
puxam para trás aquela parte é e depois
vai entrar com 11 e conquistam que vocês
vão ver mais para frente tem que dobrar
deste modo fazer um triângulo de rochas
quando os lados iguais e depois cortam
procon também tem que ser mais penning
poderia ser mais pm porque eu tenho que
utilizar de pimenta dentro do cano que
vocês fizeram inicialmente americano
tubing tiver a mesma medida e vai ficar
um tempo afastado e vai fazer atrito e
vai ter a velocidade e assim as bolsas
balas vão comendo força depois do jogo
desta maneira que eu tenho mais ou menos
10 23 36 centímetros e usei dois
elásticos mas vocês podem usar um e não
os demais do q2 porque a vossa arma não
vai aguentar corrupção
vejo aqui por fita com vai pôr bastante
ficar aqui porque os elásticos vão puxar
para a frente até então se não tiver
lafita acontecer vai seguir
aí pronto sair do que ficar sem ar
não sei porque fixa pois você tem que
importar o tamanho o tamanho mais ou
menos onde devia era fácil já existente
aqui e agora parte mais importante você
tem que usar uma cola rápida uma super
cola propor um sítio novo por agora
porque porque o papel não vai aguentar a
pressão e que exerçam eu vou aguentar só
quando vocês acharem que ele e não vai
ser opção para disparar porque o papel
faz muito atrito assim entre elas a cair
agora se vocês quiserem cola aí vai
ficar uma e plástico cai então o tributo
em três superfícies vai ficar muito
menor e que vai ser possível disparar
não sei explicar tudo bem vocês vão ver
mais para frente
ok então basicamente nestas três
partículas vocês fizerem porém mais para
ficar mais resistente tudo bem e vai
junto
a gente tem um cheiro caiu em colo e
mexa um crime não fique maior com a cola
vocês fizeram lá fora e assim não se
mexe
é aí vejo agora é só encaixar as partes
todas o elat vai lá pra frente como
vocês dariam para que ela faça alguma
atenção às bolas é só controlar o papel
bastante simples aquele só por um tio
avô e tutorial aqui mas depois voltei
atrás porque eu deixei aquela que não
fica muito né
é esse o desafio e espero que tenham
gostado se vocês quiserem ajudar o canal
e só deixaram um like e se inscrevam
para acompanhar as coisas que eu faço e
claro só vocês usem proteção
inicialmente é muito bonito mas é sempre
bom usar em proteção porque vocês podem
ver temos um disparo ainda volta um
peeling para trás a cair até papel mas
mesmo assim proteção nunca é demais
então é isso muito obrigado até a
próxima
e obrigado pelos quais 100 mil
crítica é mesmo estou muito contente
sauber e tal